In this video, I'll be introducing the concept of subsets and supersets
The dots on the board here represent elements of a set.
The lines represent the sets themselves.
These lines have been labeled B, A and U
We can say that B is a subset of A because B contains...because all elements of B are elements of A
We can also say that B is a proper subset of A because all elements of B are elements of A
and there are elements of A that are not within the set B.
We can also say that the set A is a superset of the set B because A contains all of the elements of B.
And being even more specific, we can say that A is a proper superset of B because A contains all elements of B
and there are elements of A that are not elements of B.
What we cannot say is that U is a proper subset of A.
Although the circle here is bigger than A, it just takes up more space, it doesn't contain any more elements
So all the elements...so U contains all elements of A
however, U does not contain any extra elements.
So U is a subset of A, and A is actually a subset of U
U is a superset of A, and A is also a superset of U
So the sets A and U in this case are actually equal.